how long do you think uh this game has
left chat if you had to give it a
how how much long do you think this game
has before it either dies
or something maybe a
sequel is made
which i think is what they're working on
a week
a week
[Music]
10 years
hey cs go still killing it so that would
make sense man
eight years so you guys are giving it a
good amount of time
i'd say the same i don't really know i
can't
can't exactly answer that
i'm gonna try and bop that down to slays
slays didn't get it we'll get a little
bumpy doodle here
get some boosties just play third man
i don't think danny's gonna get that
well he got it but not very well then i
just dick my teammate
okay
unfortunately i had no one to pass it to
like i missed the boost
they're not posting their ages
okay that guy backflip so we're gonna go
oh i could have ground pitched it
this is not good
danny should be okay oh he was not okay
i'm out of my flow
just let my teammates double commit let
him be cringe
i should not have tried to shoot that
that was way too hard of a shot
eight years without a sequel two to
three with
i like that alchemist
that's a
very spot-on inference
i think i i agree with you
[Music]
if anything the game will be updated to
unreal engine five pretty sooner rather
than later
for sure
terrible shot i could have made that
just gonna go back here
uh oh that's unfortunate
just bump that guy off it's always cool
to bump the guy if you can't hit the
ball
oh
our boy danny is chasing bro
i love it
clean air dribble couldn't get it in
that's what she said
play back playing a lot of back here
[Music]
timmy's in that
definitely made that difficult
couldn't get the bump
good shot danny
never mind
danny
danny oh my god
well
that's too high
come on danny there you go baby
you just need to give danny
like three tries and you'll get it
that's good to hear mossy i'm glad you
enjoy it
i'm doing my best
oh i did not think the ball would be
over here
play third man again
solo queueing ranked probably a lot of
defense going on here
i am dead i'm definitely dead get off me
cringe lord
okay
oh i definitely need to play the net
here
holy good shot
good shot
esports is massive at the moment yeah i
agree
how long you been playing for about six
years
six years
[Music]
okay we're going to control this
but left
but left again bank it off the wall
i knew danny would be there baby danny's
there for everything
oh okay i was there if it went in
danny oh
thank you easy pog
oh i can go for that but danny kind of
cut me off that's okay though
i'm gonna bang that
that was a miss
that was a goal if that guy didn't
double touch that
good touch
oh danny
my 50 sucked honestly
but danny should be hitting that ball
for sure
i think he got bumped i don't know
thanks again for all the follows chad i
really appreciate it let's try and get
this dub
that's a good bounce
i could tell that was definitely gonna
be a struggle for the guy on the wall so
i just went for it
[Music]
goodnight blakes
have a good one man
okay stay back here
not what i wanted to do at all
it was just kind of awkward
i didn't want to screw over my teammates
it was like the only thing that was on
my mind there
so i hit it out mid then it makes it
harder for them
so i just needed to be patient but i
didn't get a good touch on it
go for a shot maybe
i could have got a bump there
danny cutting everything off man
oh i could have hit it
it's
okay mid potential
oh
shouldn't have gone for it that was
stupid
nice they whiffed
so do we
come on
yeah it's just not a good opportunity
there
um i have no idea why both of my
teammates are going for that that's
really strange
but whatever
and then they're not going for that okay
this is weird
we're out here throwing
that's gonna be a tough touch
fog
we might need to go back here yeah we
definitely do
it's just missed bro do you feel threes
is an easier game mode to rank up in
compared to twos
definitely not
if you're solo queuing no
if you're with a team yes
um solo queueing absolutely not it's
torture
most of the time
i hope hopefully danny's not playing
passive defense here
that would be cringe
oh we get them dubs though good shot pog
good shot man
that was a good game we had 15 shots and
they had four chat we did not have a
single save so defense was literally
non-existent but we did get the win so
we'll take it man
we'll take it dude
teach me your ways
teach me your ways thank you so much for
the cold thank you man
thank you for gifting us of the tenacity
let me put you on the chalkboard welcome
tenacity to the agency
thanks to cole thank you bro i
appreciate you man
thank you thank you thank you
this mic is way too close to my face um
i don't need to go for that i'm just
gonna get back and help out my boy
should be okay
oh i didn't touch that somehow i really
thought i got a touch on that
[Music]
that guy turned so fast
i have not gotten boost since kickoff
i don't want to hit the ball to the
other team so we're going to do that
oh we got it under him too let's go baby
blocker child how are you man
that's just controlling the touch there
chat there's really nothing to it
i just you know i went up in the air and
i adjusted my aerial so that i didn't
hit it to the other team which you never
want to do
and it led to a goal
and then i whiff a ball sick
uh he can't score that
so we're gonna hit it to the side our
teammate got the boost so we can move up
here
um
okay
that guy just didn't go for the ball
thick dude
high tier game play here
i'm gonna hit this ball to the right
i think my my teammate went to the other
side for some reason that's kind of odd
for him to go across the field like that
but whatever
see how this guy handles it great
control he lost it though so we're gonna
challenge him
don't know why my teammates all the way
over there that's pretty stupid
typical typical this should spawn it did
right after i drove over it i hate this
game
pass it something
okay that's a good 50 but a terrible
recovery
and a really bad boost grab and we
deserve to get scored on i
don't know what i was doing there
i don't know what our boy's doing
but that was not good
you just have to be a sub here on twitch
uh there are some stream days where i do
coaching
alchemist answer your question
okay
i did not want to i want to hit that
ball top right because i knew he was
going to go across and that's a really
hard save for him but i kind of hit it
weird
and hit it right at him but i hit it
soft enough to where it was awkward for
him
nice
we'll take the goal man we'll take any
goal as it comes
okay
fake like i'm not going for it we're
gonna do a soft touch because i didn't
want to hit it directly into his pie
into his into his car
not good gonna hit it around him
give my teammate time to go
i unfortunately rotated into my
teammates so that made that pretty
difficult
we got a guy to jump for that ball
though
that's just really unlucky i got bumped
into my teammate
we're gonna make it work
i'm in this guy's brain apparently it
should spawn
right after i drove over it i hate this
game
yet again i'm half a second off of my
boost grabs
sick
i can grab this boost because i know
that's the last one i took we're good
my teammates got space and time didn't
get to say or get the goal and i got
bald [ __ ] man
uh
i got bald there that's a really good
cut
i did not expect them to turn there that
was wicked man
great shot
chat if you play 2v2s please make sure
you're cheating on kickoffs i'd really
appreciate it
it is to your benefit to do so i don't
know why people don't
because that made that
easy kickoff
a goal
yeah pretty much alchemists
okay
it's just not our ball so we don't need
to be in that play
um
it kind of looks like he's going to keep
going
i'm going gonna take control here
fake it
i got bodied on the 50 though unfortu
probably should have gone for a demo of
some kind i'm gonna help him clear it
[Music]
walk it away from that guy's possession
it should spawn now
yep there it is
i was like i don't i wasn't sure if my
teammate got it or not but he didn't
my teammate panicked pretty heavy there
this is gonna be bad
bad situation at this point
just conserving boost i'm gonna try and
get it out just get it out of the play
since we don't have boost
nice i can go for this since he
backflips
i don't know why he backflip that was
weird
you need to cuddy huddy
okay
please cheat up on your kickoffs chat it
literally is going to lead to a goal
because he just didn't cheat up
there's no point in not cheating up on
kickoffs and twos no point please do it
i'm going to try and put this in the
corner because he does not like to cheat
up in twos
there you go that's what you want
and he still gave it away to the other
team sick
i try to help the man and he still
didn't do
what we wanted him to do
damn
unfortunate dude my teammate does not
want to win this game without it being a
fight from the word go
i'm gonna move up into this cause looks
like he's playing that really slow
it's going to be really awkward
because my teammate is just like
refusing to help at this point we got a
good doinkers
that's a really good goal
that guy's been turning for every ball
this entire game
so i knew if i could get a doink around
him
it works
so that's a clean goal
very very clean doink
okay i'm just gonna avoid getting demoed
that's a really bad touch
but that's a worse touch by fall to be
honest
i want to hit that a little bit softer
that's all i can say about that
that was such a good shot it just didn't
go in man unfortunate let's hit it down
to our teammate
sick
i can't go for it based on where my
teammate is
now i can this guy's definitely going
for it this guy always goes for it so i
know what to do
the other team played the exact same way
the entire game even when it wasn't
working so it was really easy to adjust
to their play style they just go for
everything so you can just
know that they are and
counter it basically
how does that bounce out i don't know
but it did
gg
easy game man not an easy game our
teammate pretty much didn't want to win
that game
but
we got the dub anyway because we
adjusted and made you know the right
moves
good stuff